[Music]
from the director of that other horror
franchise starring Patrick Wilson in a
haunted house comes to film is based on
the 100% true ghost stories of a head
and Lorraine Warren and it's a shame
when her brothers settled that lawsuit
against them because they almost had to
go to trial to prove that ghosts were
real oh man that sounds way more fun
than Annabelle the conjuring one and to
meet the Warrens two of the least funny
Ghostbusters Lorraine is a combination
of Doctor Strange and Jean Grey
while Edie is also there it's so small
and light together they'll tackle the
biggest case of their lives in conjuring
one while in conjuring 2 they will
tackle the other biggest case of their
lives so you've heard this story before
in hit films that will lay the
groundwork for a growing MCU style
shared spooky verse but instead of
aliens in action its demons in Latin and
innocent prey Leo and the franchise's
signature touch extremely long sequences
of tension building silence
come on enough of the anticipation porn
give me scare balls prepare for two
haunting tales about families with so
many kids you won't keep anyone straight
except the dude from office space I'm
gonna need you to go ahead and come in
tomorrow watch as it becomes clear they
bought their homes without doing even
the most basic inspections sake we have
a cellar are sent to for tossing out any
of the old haunted furniture
my ex-husband bought all the furniture
but the house
and got stuck living with every haunted
house cliche in the book like lady
clocks the clock stopped at 3:07 a.m.
creepy fog creepy lakes creepy basements
creepy sellers creepy crawl spaces
creepy animals creepy children's toys
any spirits creepy children's toys even
more creepy children's toys and enough
creepy history to fill an actual history
book she's only the woman accused of
witchcraft in Salem when the baby was
seven days old jetson caught her
sacrificing it in front of the fire but
cursed anyone who tried to take her land
and hung there was another boy who
drowned in a pond here she had a boy
named Rory who disappeared and killed
herself and worked as a maid in a
neighboring home alright that's enough
I think the real evil force at work here
was the real estate company who kept
selling the place forget the epic demons
of myth and legend cuz these ones are
laying unthreatening and they smell like
tunes there's this awful smoke reeks
like something's died and stop sorry
really stinks whether it's a witch who
can be contained by a bedsheet a nun
with the same weaknesses as
Rumpelstiltskin your name gives me
dominion over you demon or the ghost of
Elvis Presley Oh
[Music]
thank you you can be sure that no matter
what they're capable of these beasts
will stick to the conventional 3x
structure of most screenplays the three
stages of demonic activity infestation
oppression and possession let me guess
admit at fifteen they save a cat or kill
a dog close enough so buckle up for a
return to decent horror after years of
found-footage Drac that has an entire
hall of spin-offs ready to go just try
not to think about how fake these ghost
hunters probably were I mean they
couldn't be as full of it as the ones on
TV right my name is zak bagans it's
horrible starring slowly walking down
stairs lights burning out
[Music]
chairs moving around
what happened what the hell happened are
you okay
okay
God doors slammed doors
[Music]
than yours
and doors they go
[Music]
[Applause]
residents evil oh em gee it's Taylor
Swift bacon has you on the menu I am
talking Daleks are not robots
if you're gonna spew spew into this with
your normal everyday voice held my voice
broke